so it's August 5th 2010 a massive
collapse at the San Jose copper mine in
northern Chile has left 33 men trapped
half-a-mile Hut's to Empire State
building's below some of the hardest
rock in the world they will find their
way to a small refuge designed for this
purpose where they will find intense
heat filth and about enough food for two
men for 10 days above ground it doesn't
take long for the experts to figure out
that there is no solution no drilling
technology in the industry is capable of
getting through rock that hard and that
deep fast enough to save their lives
it's not exactly clear where the refuge
is it's not even clear if the miners are
alive it's not even clear who's in
charge yet within 70 days all 33 of
these men will be brought to the surface
alive this remarkable story is a case
study in the power of teaming sowhat's
teaming teaming is teamwork on-the-fly
its coordinating and collaborating with
people across boundaries of all kinds
expertise distance time zone you name it
to get work done
think of your favorite sports team okay
because this is different sports teams
work together that magic write those
game saving plays now they win sports
teams win because they practice but you
can only practice if you have the same
members over time and so you can think
of teaming so it sports teams embody the
definition of a team
the formal definition it's a stable
bounded reasonably small group of people
who are interdependent in achieving a
shared outcome you can think of teaming
as a kind of pickup game in the park in
contrast to the formal well practice
team now which one's gonna win in a
playoff the answer is obvious
right so why do I study teaming it's
because it's the way more and more of us
have to work today
all right with 24/7 global fast-paced
operations crazy shifting schedules and
ever narrower expertise more and more of
us have to work with different people
all the time to get our work done right
we don't have the luxury of stable teams
now when you can have that luxury by all
means do it but increasingly for a lot
of the work we do today we don't have
that option one place where this is true
is hospitals this is where I've done a
lot of my research over the years so it
turns out hospitals they have to be open
24/7 and patients well they're all
different right they're all different in
complicated in unique ways so the
average hospitalized patient is seen by
60 or so different caregivers throughout
his stay they come from different shifts
different specialties different you know
different areas of expertise and they
may not even know each other's name but
they have to coordinate in order for the
patient to get great great care and when
they don't the results can be tragic of
course in teaming the stakes aren't
always life-and-death right consider
what it takes to create an animated film
write an award-winning animated film I
had the good fortune to go to Disney
Animation and study over 900 scientists
artists storytellers computer scientists
as they teamed up in constantly changing
configurations to create amazing
outcomes like frozen alright they just
they just work together and never the
same group twice not knowing what's
going to happen next now taking care of
patients in the emergency room I'm
designing an animated film are obviously
very different work yet underneath the
differences they have a lot in common
right you have to get different
expertise at different times you don't
have fixed roles you don't have fixed
deliverables you're going to be doing a
lot of things that have never been done
before and you can't do it in
a stable team now this way of working
isn't easy but as I said it's more and
more the way many of us have to work so
we have to understand it and I would
argue that it's especially needed for
work that's complex and unpredictable
and for for solving big problems right
so Paul Polman the Unilever CEO put this
really well when he said the issues we
face today are so big and so challenging
it becomes quite clear we can't do it
alone
and so there's a certain humility in
knowing you have to invite people in
right issues like food or water scarcity
cannot be done by individuals even by
single companies even by single sectors
right so we're reaching out to team
across in big teaming grand scale
teaming take the quest for smart cities
right maybe you've seen some of the
rhetoric right mixed use designs zero
net energy building smart mobility you
know green livable wonderful cities so
we have the vocabulary we have the
visions not to mention the need we have
the technology to mega trends at
urbanization we're fast becoming a more
urban planet and climate change have
been increasingly pointing to cities as
a crucial target for innovation and now
around the world in various locations
people have been teaming up to design
and try to create green livable smart
cities it's a massive Innovation
Challenge to understand it better I
studied a start-up a smart city software
startup as it teamed up with a real
estate developer some civil engineers a
mayor let's see an architect some
builders some tech companies their goal
was to build a demo smart city from
scratch okay five years into the project
not a whole lot had happened six years
still no ground broken
it seemed that teaming across industry
boundaries was really really hard
Hey so I had inadvertently I think her
we had inadvertently discovered what I
call professional culture clash with
this project you know software engineers
and real estate developers think
differently really differently right
different values different time frames
time frames is a big one and and and
different jargon different language and
so they don't always see eye to eye I
think this is a bigger problem than most
of us realize in fact I think
professional culture clash is a major
barrier to building the future that we
aspire to build and so it becomes a you
know problem that we have to understand
a problem that we have to figure out how
to crack so how do you make sure teaming
goes well especially big teaming this is
the question I've been trying to solve
for a number of years in many different
workplaces with my research now to begin
to get just a glimpse of the answer to
this question let's go back to Chile in
Chile we witnessed ten weeks of teaming
by hundreds of individuals from
different professions different
companies different sectors even
different nations and as as this process
unfolded you know they they had lots of
ideas they tried many things they
experimented they failed they
experienced devastating daily failure
but they picked up persevered and and
went on forward and you know really what
we witness there what we witnessed there
was that they were able to be humble in
the face of the very real challenge
ahead curious all of these diverse
individuals diverse expertise especially
nationality as well we're quite curious
about what each other's bring and they
were willing to take risks to learn fast
or to learn fast what might work and
ultimately 17 days into this remarkable
story ideas came from everywhere right
they came from andre sougarret who was a
brilliant mining engineer who was
appointed by the government to lead the
rescue they came from NASA they came
from Chilean special
forces they came from volunteers around
the world and while many of us including
myself watched from afar
these folks made slow painful progress
through the rock on the 17th day they
broke through to the refuge it's just a
remarkable moment and with a small just
a very small incision they were able to
find it through a bunch of experimental
techniques and then for the next 53 days
that narrow lifeline would be the path
where food and medicine and
communication would travel while
above-ground for 53 more days they
continued the teaming to find a way to
create a much larger whole and also to
design a capsule this is the capsule and
then on the 69th day over 22 painstaking
hours they managed to pull the miners
out one by one so how did they overcome
professional culture clash I would say
in a word it's leadership but let me be
more specific
when teaming works you can be sure that
some leaders leaders at all levels have
been crystal clear that they don't have
the answers let's call this situational
humility right it's appropriate humility
right we don't know how to do it you can
be sure as I said before people were
very curious and this situational
humility combined with curiosity creates
a sense of psychological safety that
allows you to take risks with strangers
because let's face it it's hard to speak
up right it's hard to ask for help it's
hard to offer an idea that might be a
stupid idea
if you don't know people very well you
need psychological safety to do that so
they overcame what I like to call the
basic human challenge right it's hard to
learn if you already know right and
unfortunately we're hardwired to think
we know and so we got to remind
ourselves and we can do it to be curious
to be curious about what others bring
and that curiosity can also spawn a kind
of generosity of interpretation but
there's another barrier right there's
another barrier and you all know it it
wouldn't be
in this room if you didn't know it and
to explain it I'm gonna quote from the
movie the Paper Chase this by the way is
what Hollywood thinks a Harvard
professor is supposed to look like you
you be the judge so the professor in
this famous scene he's welcoming the new
1l class and he says look to your left
look to your right one of you won't be
here next year what message did they
hear right it's me or you for me to
succeed you must fail now I don't think
too many organizations welcome newcomers
that way anymore
but still many times people arrive with
that message of scarcity anyway right
it's me or you it's awfully hard to team
if you inadvertently see others as
competitors so where you have to
overcome that one as well and when we do
the results can be awesome Abraham
Lincoln said once I don't like that man
very much I must get to know him better
think about that right I don't like him
it means I don't know him well enough
it's extraordinary right so this is the
mindset I have to say this is the
mindset you need for effective teaming
so in our silos we can get things done
but when we step back and reach out and
reach across miracles can happen miners
can be rescued patients can be saved
beautiful films can be created to get
there I think there's no better advice
than this look to your left look to your
right how quickly can you find the
unique talents skills and hopes of your
neighbor and how quickly in turn can you
convey what you bring because for us to
team up to build the future we know we
can create that none of us can do alone
that's the mindset we need thank you
[Applause]
[Music]